seven-one-seven our next caller is from
the seven-one-seven area code caller
please go ahead tell us who you are
yes I'm Logan I've called in before
first I just want to say I love what you
do but I do have a little bit of a I
guess disagreement about how you and the
independent media presents themselves so
all right first let me let me let me
pose a question please do you consider
do you consider yourself as well as
people like Pyle kolinsky and chanc
euchre journalists uh
journalists to me is become a weird one
to define I mean I think a better
question is am i a reporter or a
commentator or an analyst you know
journalist is it's very difficult at
this point to say who is a journalist
because there's usually an implicit
definition there I mean if you're asking
me if I'm a reporter no I'm not a
reporter okay cause like my issue is my
issue with the independent media is that
the independent media tries to pass that
they are so much better than the
mainstream media like the CNN and the
Fox News when the MSNBC are usually like
that Lakers I think there's a difference
in what who in independent media says
that they're better than corporate media
um namely I kind of like to point
fingers at the Young Turks but I think I
I think a lot of them kind of follow in
that same sort of path what listen I
can't speak for them but what I can tell
you is pointing out that independent
media is not constrained nor funded nor
influenced in the same way as corporate
media that's not saying that it is
better if you're looking for media that
is maybe less dictated by what's going
to generate revenue that might be a
reason you might prefer independent
media but the value judgment of better
or worse
I don't know I'm not making it well I
mean yeah obviously that's an I think
obviously that's an opinion thing but I
don't know like Logan you're breaking up
it sounds like we're having an
incredibly limited cell phone service
right now we can just barely hear you
now oh I'm sorry
Logan well yeah I don't know if this is
better or not my issue is it's not
really the only real difference that
I've ever seen with the mainstream media
and the independent media is that the
independent media is just more overtly
biased to one side like Alex Jones is
more overtly biased to the right now but
here's the problem Logan you're
experiencing a bit of a deficit in terms
of a bit of media literacy that would be
relevant because when you say
independent media is more overtly biased
than corporate media the term bias
applies differently if you're talking
about opinion journalism or news
reporting and I think this gets back to
your initial question of am i a
journalist because if you consider that
Brooke Baldwin on CNN is doing the same
thing that I'm doing then you would say
Wow well David is clearly much more
biased than Brooke Baldwin is because he
seems to state way more of his opinions
on the air the difference is I am I am
an opinion journalist right or a
commentator whatever term you want to
use so the term bias is different than
what would be applied to someone like
Brooke Baldwin who is presumably a
reporter of news I think that you've got
to first figure out some of the
differences and nuances of types of
media before you can make such a blanket
statement that independent media is just
more biased there might what you might
be saying is there's more opinion
journalism and independent media is that
maybe what you mean yeah oh okay yeah
well dad I agree with you on that that I
agree with you on and and who could
argue against that
okay thanks very much for the call Logan
I think it's becoming sort of a semantic
discussion at this point